hey youtube you said you wanted to talk
what's up why do you go around making
other people look stupid what do you
mean what's water made of yeah what
makes water okay what elements does it
take to make water h2o so what does that
mean it is water okay okay so that was
one example really the cover dog side
you know everything emits carbon dioxide
in the trees human beings I guess like
animals and trees are contributing to
the are definitely but it's definitely
so yeah so what trees are I guess the
you know want the one of the original
primary sources of for emitters of co2
so trees you know trees are just like
anything else in on this earth that
emits us Comeau dioxide I could do this
all day you know you know you know what
I think I think you do it to make
yourself look superior oh yeah maybe
that's it maybe I'm just a giant
egotistical jerk who delights and
humiliating other people well that fact
certainly hasn't gone unnoticed by your
viewers you come across a little
condescending in these interviews you
basically set up every single question
to make other people look like idiots
this guy is a pretentious douchebag
now that's hurtful I hate this YouTube
channel it makes every single person
that interviews look like a complete
[ __ ] not everyone's a physicist so get
the [ __ ] over stop alright my viewers
don't own me actually you should have
read those T's and C's a little more
carefully by seeing your ads your
viewers do in fact own you oh man yeah
now come on just between you and me how
closely do you have to pick through
those interviews to make people look
that dumb I mean some of them if you
want to see the complete interviews then
why don't you click the annotation you
can judge for yourself did you ever
think that the reason that I start with
the misconceptions is because I wrote my
PhD on how to design films to teach
physics and I found that if you just say
the correct stuff trees get most of
their mass from carbon dioxide
yep pretty much covers it viewers don't
actually learn anything they just feel
like they're learning and become more
confident in the things that they
thought beforehand so what you're saying
is you make people look stupid so that
you can teach others how noble but
that's just if I don't think these
people are stupid there's a difference
between being unknowledgeable and being
unintelligent i mean i i'm
unknowledgeable about lots of stuff and
science can be hard for the particular
reason that it's counterintuitive so I
think we should acknowledge what
everyone's thinking what most people are
thinking and use that as our basis for
teaching but if you actually believe
that why does your face light up with
glee every time you hear a misconception
because in that moment I realize that I
can be useful I can help people learn
the truth and that's the point of
veritasium to help people understand the
truth of the natural world and to get
them to seek the truth in their own
lives as Richard Fineman said the first
principle is that you must not fool
yourself and you are the easiest person
to fool
this guy is a pretentious douchebag